( intro music )
( applause )
Good morning.
It has been a truly
exciting week for me.
It's a very empowering
experience for me
to get to know my fellow
emerging explorers.
For me, I'm passionate
about energy problems.
I hope we can have
a sustainable energy future.
Growing up in China,
in the period
that the cultural revolution
was in the past,
China has opened up
its doors to look for
better economy
and better lives.
Our lives are getting
better and better,
but energy is always scarce.
I remember I used
to watch my Mom
working in the kitchen
under very dim light
trying to save electricity.
About 10 years ago,
my parents bought
a solar thermal system.
Like many city people,
they live in apartments,
those high-rise buildings.
They installed a solar system
on the rooftop of
their building.
Such a system will heat
up their domestic water
so they can have
access to hot water,
and that makes a huge difference
for their life quality.
Like many families, they want to
install such systems
on the rooftop
and it becomes a competition.
Everyone wants a space there.
One day my father said,
"It will be really nice,
we can hang
solar thermal panels
outside our window,
the piping will be
simpler, and everyone
will have access to
the renewable energy."
That makes me think
about there really
is a strong need
for this kind of
flexible and lightweight
solar systems.
That motivates me
to develop later on
the solar cell stickers,
and this work is done
by my students and me
at Stanford University.
The solar stickers
are like downside
just like the stickers
your kids put on
your clothes to say,
'Thank you, Mom,'
'Good job, Mom.'
( laughter )
You peel them off
and then stick it
to anywhere you want,
so that we can increase
the places we can
use solar energy.
The reason I'm interested in
solar energy is very simple.
There is abundant
resources of solar energy.
Here we show
the world's energy resources.
The big one in the center is
the annual energy from the sun.
The ones on the right-hand side
are from the finite resources.
For example, the petroleum,
coal, natural gas, etc.
The small circles in the center
represent those
renewable sources,
their annual energy output,
for example, wind,
geothermal, etc.
The two blue dots on
the very left-hand side
represent our annual
consumption of energy.
The smaller one is about energy
consumption in 2010.
The bigger one is
the estimated energy consumption
in 2015.
You can see our
energy consumption is increasing
as we want to preserve
our lifestyle
and people from
developing countries
are looking for
better life quality.
If we continue to
rely on fossil fuels,
we are going to
deplete them one day,
sooner or later,
because we are using them
simply at a rate much faster
than can be regenerated.
We have to rely more and more
on renewable energy
and solar is a
wonderful resource.
We are using solar energy now.
We are using it
in the form of solar panels.
You probably all have
seen this kind of
flat panel looking thing,
dark color, facing the sun.
Those solar panels
essentially
is a sun-powered battery.
When the sun illuminates
those solar panels,
they will generate
electron holes.
The flow of
electrons in the holes
will generate current
and that current
powers the electrical load.
For example, your
phones, a lamp, etc.
You can think
about the solar cell
as a sun-powered battery
constantly charged by sunlight.
If we look a little deeper
into the solar cells,
a solar cell just like
a battery, as I mentioned,
as all batteries you will have
a positive and a negative side.
The greyish color
on the top and the bottom
are the positive
and negative part.
They are metallic layers.
What's in between
is semiconductor,
frequently silicon,
that can absorb sunlight
and generate electron hole
that drives the current.
You can think about from
the structure perspective,
this solar cell looks
like a sandwich.
It's the semiconductor
sandwiched
between two electrodes.
If this whole thing is as thin
as one type of solar cell
called a thin film solar cell,
then it has the potential
to become
flexible and lightweight.
If we look at the key parameters
we characterize solar cell,
the one parameter
is called efficiency.
How much power can
be generated
comparing to how much power
is incident by sunlight?
In other words, what
percentage of sun power
you can convert to electricity?
For most solar cells
in the market,
it's about 10 to 20 percent.
For example, if we have
15 percent solar panels,
if you have one square
centimeter area,
you can generate
about 150 watts.
That's enough to power
two to three lamps.
If I have a rock
the size of this rug,
it will probably roughly
generate about 500 watts.
That's the magnitude.
To increase the energy
production by solar cells,
one is to increase efficiency;
the other to increase the area
you want to use it.
We want to make them
to be able
to apply it
not only on rooftops.
For example, these are
the rooftop solar panels
at Stanford, that's over
the Business Center,
and those are great
for rooftop applications.
But as I mentioned,
we want to increase the places.
There's only limited
space on rooftops.
It will be nice
if we can put on cars,
or maybe on the side
walls of buildings,
then those solar cells
have to be flexible.
What's the challenge?
This is how solar
cell looks like,
called the thin-film
solar cells.
The bluish color
is the sandwich structure,
that's the solar cell
that's the actual part
that generates electricity.
Those things have
to be manufactured
on the substrate.
The substrate is
the holder for them.
The substrate
typically is glass
or silicon wafer
or stainless steel.
The solar cell part is
only a couple microns,
about one-tenth of the thickness
of the plastic food wrap
you use.
That's very thin, very flexible.
But the substrate
is about a millimeter scale.
It's about a thousand
times thicker.
That's the part that
causes the solar cells
to be heavy, to be rigid.
But we need those
substrates as a holder
to fabricate the material.
During the fabrication,
they put the substrate there
and they deposit material
on top.
It's similar as the process
as ladies doing make-up,
we have the face
as the substrate,
we put layers and
layers of materials
and they are very thin,
so they don't show up very much.
The idea here is
if we can replace
the rigid substrate
by something flexible,
for example, paper or plastic,
then essentially we can
have a flexible substrate.
But we cannot directly
just stick the paper
into the solar
cell manufacturers.
They cannot sustain
the environment,
the temperature, the chemicals.
We are required to
manufacture solar cells.
So what do we do?
It's the inspiration from food.
( laughter )
It's the pizza approach.
When we bake the pizza,
we put this pizza
in a ceramic pan.
The ceramic pan can sustain the
high temperature in your oven
to cook the pizza.
But when we deliver the pizza,
we transfer that pizza out,
put it in the paper box.
That's much cheaper
so we can have pizza
at a very economical price.
( laughter )
When we look at the pizza,
essentially we have two carriers
for two different functions.
The pan is for the
high temperature
manufacturing process,
and the paper is for
the delivery and
transportation purpose.
We can do the same
thing for solar cells.
This is how we do it.
This is again the two-layer
structure I showed you.
The blue is the solar
cell and the bottom
is the thick glass
or silicon wafers.
What we do differently
is we insert
a metallic layer in between,
and that layer serves
as a sacrificial layer later on.
The solar cells will
be manufactured
as identical procedures
and conditions
as your regular
thin-film solar cells.
What we do next
is we soak it in water.
Room temperature water,
just the tap water,
and inside water
we just peel it.
During this peeling process,
the metallic layer separates
from the substrate, the glass.
Now we have this thin
solar cell coming out,
kind of like when ladies
apply the face mask.
Sometimes you paint
it and when you remove it,
it comes off as entire layer.
It's the same thing
but we have water there.
Now the thin solar cells,
as I mentioned,
is only a couple microns.
It's very thin
and you can stick it
like a sticker to the back
of your cell phones.
That realizes
the transfer process.
Now we have two substrates.
One for fabrication,
one as the carrier
when you use it.
The magical part to me
is really
what happens in the water,
and that is where
we have worked on.
This shows the process in water.
What you have
is a four-inch wafer
with the metallic layer
on silicon.
My students are
just working through the edges,
trying to make sure
the edges are clean.
You can see in the initial
one-half minute,
he's just working
through the edges,
and then only within
a few seconds,
he peeled off the entire thing.
What you see in the
front is the silicon wafer
that you can use for
the fabrication of solar cells.
You can see, after this process,
it's very clean so
you can use it again,
just like the pans for pizza,
for solar cell fabrications.
The one on the back,
the shiny part,
is the metallic layer
and the solar cells
come in behind that.
Now you have
a solar cell sticker.
You can stick it to anywhere.
This process only requires water
and is really fast.
You can see this takes
less than two minutes.
We collaborated with National
Renewable Energy Lab.
They fabricated this
amorphous silicon solar cell
on our modified silicon wafers.
Those circles
are the solar cells.
After this peel-off process,
we attached it to
my business card.
It's very flexible.
This is the initial
silicon wafer
and it's very clean.
You can use it again.
The key parameter for
solar cell is efficiency.
After this transfer process,
the efficiency remains the same.
That means the process
is so gentle,
it doesn't damage
the solar cell.
That's the key.
This peel technology,
we think
can really go beyond solar cell.
It really doesn't depend
on the solar cell.
We are just controlling
the interface.
If you replace the solar cells
with thin-film electronics,
for example, display.
We can have flexible
displays, or batteries.
We can have thin-film batteries,
or sensors for human
health monitoring
or environmental monitoring,
or any other thin-film
electronic devices
you can imagine.
It is a very powerful technique
for flexible electronics.
With this technique,
I dream one day
we can stick those
solar cells
to the side wall
of the buildings,
to the shade of your windows,
to your helmet,
to the back of your phones,
your iPad, to your backpack.
With that, we can
power the world,
and with that,
we can contribute
to a sustainable energy future.
Thank you very much.
( applause )
( outro music )